I enjoyed the dynamic between the three
of you I'm curious of the characters
that you played in the dodeca what parts
were like you personally that you were
able to tap into and then what parts
were nothing like you whether it was the
role of the victim or the antagonizer or
the peacemaker ladies first yeah okay
well I think especially with movies like
this where it's scripted and yet heavily
improvised you bring a lot of yourself
to to the role a lot of your own
personal experiences the cadence of how
you talk in real life so a lot of that
is like me am very kind of nurturing
person a very eternal person but I'm
also super competitive so as an actor
working on a film where I'm supposed to
be the peacemaker and not the competitor
has a little tricky for me because I
wanted to go and play with them and
compete against them and try to hold my
own with them so I would try to create
competitions between us after we were
done shooting at night you know pretty
much anything I could think of r kelly
and i had a couple competitions together
okay anything you want to share I mean
yeah we had a shot gunning of a beer
competition and I was you know of course
confidently certain I was gonna win and
Jen him at first I think is that the
first beer you shotgun rear D we can say
it was I thought was maybe so that's why
I got overconfident but she she
destroyed me there's a crowning moment
for me and then what am I match what
about the strip poker competition you
won then well yeah I'm making a first is
that that's winning right and for Mark
and Steve and the thing that you brought
that was truly like your real selves in
real life to the character and what
parts were okay I'll see for myself um
you know I have an older
other so I definitely was able to draw
upon that relationship in the film and
especially when it came time to
improvise some of those scenes I was
literally at living true stories from my
childhood for example the opening
sequence when I'm in the bathtub I my
older brother really did defecate in the
bathtub while we were bathing together
just sort of taunt and torture me
scarred me for life clearly um but hey
then I got to use it in a movie so it's
all good thank you for having the
courage for me I definitely drew upon a
lot of personal things I'm the youngest
of three boys and so I was playing the
younger brother and had that the drawn
and then also specifically in the movie
is seen when we're fighting at the end
of the movie and I really wanted to
bring in the throwing of me and the bark
dust under the flower bed area it was
just a very popular thing for my holes
for the Rob had to want to do to rile me
up so um that was fun bringing that
right into the
film mortal izing it for my brother
Robin now get to see the reason here and
in terms of some of the deeper stuff um
you know at the time I was a single and
you know kind of wanting a family like
my two older brothers have families and
children and I was the uncle and it was
um it was really kind of just timing
wise heavy on me at the time and since
the movies been made them I've been
married and have a one-year-old son so
why we shot the movie before that
happened worked with mark and Jay before
right do you get to a point where you
have to audition for them or it's just
like they know you're right for a
certain role and they call you and you
don't have to read I auditions yeah I am
I wasn't even asked to audition the
first the first go around because they
just thought I was too young to play the
role but they were having her time
finding their stephanie and they asked
me to go on tape for shits and giggles
so we did that and in full disclosure my
boyfriend who is one of the co-producers
on the film was putting all the
auditions on tape and later that night I
I asked him I said I want to or watch
them I want to see what other actresses
did with the same material and I watched
so many actresses give like really
beautiful great strong auditions that
were so completely different from what I
did and I spent the night just sobbing
in my bed thinking that I was clueless
and I had no idea night because I felt
so connected to the character and I
realized that they must just not know
what I was doing but then a couple days
later they called me in that for me
so that's how I got involved with it
very nice to me I've actually been
working with these guys for a long time
for sure Greek means okay the first time
I worked with them was officially was in
2005 with a short phone called the
intervention so we've just built a
relationship since then and yeah they
just you know tap me and I said thank
you very much I will act for you again
similarly I got asked to be in the film
which is incredible phone call from Jay
and my backyard I was pacing around 10 a
few days before my 35th birthday and got
this magical texts from mark actually
first do you want to make a movie with
us and I thought you know awesome you
know wonder what the role is and this
and that and then five minutes later Jay
called and asked me the same question
and it turns out I got to be the brother
and they and it was just a magical
magical birthday gift from all time
you